Our next question is to Dr. Zakin Naik
and this is about the topic of similar
on the concept of disunityity and this
is what we see as oppression that we see
today. So now everyone around the world
Muslims and non-Muslims alike they look
at the oppression today so much rampant
injustice and they feel this sense of
helplessness. What tends to happen
though is that they look into political
ideologies for solutions. How does the
sunnah provide a superior framework for
this social justice that protects in a
way that sometimes people tend to
overlook?
>> The question poses that we do agree
there's oppression in the world a lot
with the Muslim that are non-Muslim and
we usually look up for a solution in the
political and the present ideology.
What solution is given by the sunnah for
protection against operation? As far as
the sunnah is concerned, I would think
it's not one layer of protection. The
sunnah gives a multiple layers
of shield against operation. It gives a
spiritual shield. It gives a social
shield. It gives ethical and moral
shield as well as for physical action.
The most important shield is the
spiritual shield.
And our beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said that the dua of an
oppressed person GOES DIRECTLY TO Allah
and there's no one in between.
There's a hadith in Mutaf and alike in
Bkari and Muslim. It's mentioned in Sai
Bkari had number 2448
and in Sai Muslim had number 19 that a
beloved prophet said that beware
of the dua of the person who's
oppressed. It is carried above the
clouds. And Allah says by me,
my might and my majesty,
inshallah, my by my might and my
majesty, the help is near you. Allah
directly replies that I'm going to help
you. And irrespective whether the
oppressed person is a Muslim or a
non-Muslim,
whether he's a sinner or not a sinner.
If he's oppressed person, even if he's a
non-Muslim, even if he's a sinner, Allah
hears the dua. And what did the prophet
recommend? The prophet recommended for
an oppressed person to do dua to Allah
and do dua that oh Allah
you be my shield
against
my oppressors
and I seek refuge
in you from the sh of the oppressor.
This is number one shield. I want to cut
it short. Don't want to give a lecture.
Most important shield is no one can help
you better than Allah. When you're
oppressed, number one person who can
help you the best is Allah.
And we get guidance from Allah and his
rasool for the second shield that is the
social shield. And there are levels of
that. The hadith of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam say bkari had
number 2444
where a prophet said that Allah loves a
Muslim
who
helps another Muslim
irrespective whether he's oppressor or
he's being oppressed. How do you do
that?
If I see a Muslim is being oppressed, I
go and support him for his rights. If I
see a Muslim who is oppressing, I stop
him. Whether your brother is oppressed
or being oppressed, you have to help
both the people. For example, if someone
is being robbed and if a Muslim is being
robbed, I will try and help him to
prevent being robbed. If a Muslim is
robbing, I will try and prevent him from
being from being successful in robbing
someone else.
The second level of the shield is the
hadith of say Muslim
had number 49
where our beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said when you see evil
stop it with your hand.
If you cannot stop it with the hand stop
it with the tongue. If you cannot stop
it with the tongue the least you can do
is curse in your heart and you will have
the lowest level of iman. So if I have
as a Muslim on a society level on a
spiritual level, the second is society
level. I see a wrong thing being done.
If Allah has given me the ability, I
stop it with my hand. If I see someone
is raping someone,
if I have the ability, I will stop it
with my hand. If I think no, I'm not
strong, you know, I may get killed, the
least I can do is stop it with my turn.
Tell him you stop it or cry for help. If
you fear that also the least you can do
is curse in your heart on the society
level you have to help
the person who's being oppressed
and the hadith
of Riyad had number 194 which says that
which is the best deed the best jihad
and the prophet replied the best jihad
is speaking a word of truth against a
tyrant ruler.
So if you speak the word of truth one
word against a tan ruler it is jihad.
This is on a society level. Come to the
third level of ethical and
moral
that speaks about the hadith ofi
where
it says that a beloved prophet a beloved
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
said that when you see
any evil
you have to stop it.
And the fourth is the level of actions.
Had of Maja 4210 that give charity. You
as a person who's being oppressed give
charity.
It will help you in many ways. It will
help you in washing away your sins.
So help do charities. Your actions also.
If you are being oppressed, you should
do charity. So these are the levels that
have been prescribed in the sunnah
that we can use against the operation
that's happening today in the world.